hi GQ it's Charlie puth here and today
I'm going undercover on the internet
open laptop
it's actually me
tick tock
[Music]
are you and cookie besties now
we are we don't understand each other at
all but we're besties brought together
through the power of music
[Music]
what happened to your eyebrow I got bit
by a dog when I was two years old and
it's left me with a pretty cool Scar and
I know some people purposely shave this
part of their eyebrow but I don't have
to do that posted
[Music]
so when is tour
shocked embarrassed I just did something
naughty Emoji Tor is going to be very
soon and there's going to be another
tour in 2023 as well I'll basically be
living on the road next
[Music]
what's your mixing chain for backing
vocals like harmonies slash lairs okay
well I never record in a perfect room so
I always put a noise suppressor on
channel one and I know that's incorrect
if it's a vocal I put the auto-tune on
32 retune speed and then maybe 20 and
then comes the EQ
scoop a bunch on the bottom kind of
boost up here boost a little bit more
for that Sizzle I have this widening
tool that I made it's just two stereo
doublers that I keyed through a bus and
then I kind of just gently bring it up I
don't know how interesting that is but I
was just going through my whole I mean
it was a question that they asked Reddit
how long is the Charlie puth concert
well user long jumping honey I think
it's about like an hour and 15 minutes
I try and keep it brief I'd rather have
every song be entertaining rather than
like there be a unbearable overly
artistic middle section of the concert
these are new songs you've never heard
before I always dislike that when
concerts were like three hours long I
won't name anybody and specifically but
next
hi Charlie if you were stranded on a
desert island what three things would
you have with you
James Taylor's Greatest Hits something
to listen to that on and I don't know
maybe an Apple for some Fiber
is there any song of yours that you
never want to sing again Marvin Gaye I
hate that song I'm sorry I shouldn't say
I don't like to use I take that back I
dislike that song
extraordinarily I do appreciate the way
that it makes some people feel it just
felt kind of on the nose and beginning
of my career Vibes I'm gonna get some
hate for that one
was there a time that you thought about
giving up and just going behind the
scenes just to write and produce music
perhaps why and when love from Greece I
think there was a time where I convinced
myself that maybe I wasn't going to be
the artist I was just gonna be the
songwriter it's kind of like when you
want a green light and all you're
getting are red lights when you're
driving and then when you just one
second to just chill at the red light
it's just green lights so I don't know
what that means but love from Greece
who's asking about me
on Twitter
was Charlie puth in a band how is he
famous FBI planted him
um no FBI did not plant me I've actually
been at this for a while I was 17 making
YouTube videos I kind of just wanted to
be a jazz piano player at first but just
still had that love of pop music and
always thought that there was a way to
integrate the two and that's what I
currently do replied
have scientists studied why male Idols
loved Justin Bieber and Charlie puth so
much like what are the findings I didn't
know that I was loved by K-pop Idols I
just thought I was friends with Jungkook
but I'm I'm happy to be friends with
everybody I think in the East there's a
great appreciation for jazz and I love
jazz maybe they also love the way that I
make and play music so I don't really
know how to answer that but I'm really
glad I have the love and support
from male Idols
Instagram
which funny enough used to be a
photographer's only app
and now it's obviously not
[Music]
what the f Charlie met oh yeah I met
Guru Saad such a great conversation
about how the soil is one of the most
important aspects of our Earth and
keeping it healthy just listening to his
thoughts and Prospects about life is
super interesting we're kind of rocking
a similar cut
posted
[Music]
was elton's slight in reference to the
boy era of Charlie's music Elton loved
my last album but I was making music
before the pandemic which wasn't really
authentic to me and I think he told me
to just make music that's authentic to
Me Maybe referencing songs like boy that
were authentic to me I I do love that
song I love playing that song it's very
Jazzy next
[Music]
why are you leaving thirst traps Charlie
question mark exclamation point question
mark exclamation point I just wanted to
see if these pants would fit me these
Jorts I'm sorry turns out they did I
don't know if I could sit down in them
but they worked I'd never wear Jorts it
was a special occasion didn't they
posted Wikipedia don't forget to donate
puth was credited with the production
and writing of songs and Jingles for
fellow YouTube personalities that's
correct I set up a business in 2010 to
make YouTube Jingles for anybody that
wanted one for their YouTube show and I
charged like a hundred dollars but for
the bigger YouTubers if you had like
kind of discriminatory but if you had 50
000 followers and up I you know slashed
the price in half or just disregard it
completely in exchange for a if you just
give me a little shout out at the end of
your video get a free song that's how
that all came about building up and
snowballing my YouTube audience
next
puth wrote co-produced and was featured
on a song with Wiz Khalifa who I just
spoke to see you again a tribute to the
late Paul Walker included in the fast
the infurious 7 soundtrack oh that's
true he wrote a wonderful rap to it and
it really tied the whole song together
it was a perfect cocktail of sad boy
emotion with
motivational wizness
in grade six he went door-to-door
selling a Christmas album called foreign
have a very Charlie Christmas that he
had recorded and produced making 600 in
sales which I donated
um that's also correct what they didn't
mention is that I actually made the CD
jackets in Microsoft Word 97 great
operating system
YouTube
[Music]
how can he have that deep voice and then
sing in a very high voice this guy is
awesome that's very nice I don't know I
just always wanted to sing high so I'd
always practice singing high in my
falsetto replied
[Music]
Edgar asks why don't you play empty cups
live anymore
well Edgar after an hour and some change
playing live it's very hard to sing up
there but I will consider it
okay that's it I know it's crazy but
I've actually had enough internet for
today first time in a while that's a lot